REBECCA MOORE: Welcome
to a sure-to-be-fantastic
presentation by Dr. Andrew
Steer of the World Resources
Institute.
It's my pleasure to
introduce Dr. Steer.
My name's Rebecca Moore.
I lead the Google
Earth team, which
also includes Google Earth
Engine, Google Earth Outreach,
and we're affectionately known
internally as earthlings.
My team has worked with Andrew's
team for a number of years.
I'll say a little bit
more about that later.
World Resources Institute--
it doesn't brag about it
in your bio-- but
they are considered
to be by many accounts the
most authoritative, credible
environmental research
organization in the world.
They're extremely
effective and they
work at the intersection of
science, research, policy,
economic development.
They have incredible
impact on the ground
from global to local.
They create instruments and
indices and measurements
that are the standard by which
countries all over the world
measure themselves.
They are really the
organization that
is taking a close guardianship
look over our natural resources
in a very authoritative way.
They have 450 experts that
work with leaders to address
six urgent global challenges.
with a focus on forests,
food, water, climate, energy,
and cities.
Dr. Steer joined WRI
from the World Bank
where he was special
envoy for climate change.
He's also currently co-chair of
the World Economic Forum Global
Agenda Council on
Natural Capital.
If you don't know what
natural capital is,
you should Google it.
It's a term you
should all understand.
He was educated at Saint
Andrews University, Cambridge
University, University
of Pennsylvania
with a PhD in Economics.
And again, I wanted
to just step back.
My Google Earth team-- in
particular, Google Earth Engine
and Google Earth
Outreach-- has been
working with Andrew's
team for several years
on the development of a couple
of really transformative
technology platforms.
The main one is called
Global Forest Watch,
which is the world's first
high resolution near real time
global forest monitoring system.
It's powered by
Google Earth Engine.
We work together from
the very early days
of white-boarding a design
on a Google white board
with his team.
And it launched in 2014 and
now is having fantastic impacts
that I hope that you will
speak a little bit about.
It's been a great partnership
because what Google
has to offer, of course,
is massive computational
resources, massive data,
fantastic ability to process
algorithms on this data.
But we're not the scientists.
We're not the policy people.
We don't know the
levers of change
for environmental protection.
And WRI does.
So it's been a fantastic,
fantastic partnership
with you, Global Forest Watch.
Now they're working on
Global Resources Watch,
which will also be
powered to some degree
by Google Earth Engine.
And we're really
excited that you
exist and are doing
the great work that you
do to protect,
preserve, and educate us
all about the planet.
So he's going to speak today
about stories to watch in 2016.
And please give a warm
welcome to Dr. Andrew Steer.
ANDREW STEER: Thank you.
Thank you, Rebecca
very much indeed.
It is just the most
wonderful partnership
that we have with
the earthlings.
Thank you, and friends like
David over there and Saleem,
I mean it really is a joy
to work with you guys.
You are making the world
a much, much better place.
And we are deeply
privileged to work with you.
What we do once a
year, at the beginning
of the year at the World
Resource Institute,
we get our experts
together, and we say,
what should we be watching
in the coming year?
We come up with
sort of five or six
what we call, stories to watch.
This is actually the
14th year we've done it.
And then at the end of the
year we look back and say,
did those stories turn out the
way that we hoped they would.
And so what I was going to
do today quite quickly-- I'm
going to go through quite a
lot of slides quite quickly--
is lay out five
stories for 2016.
We believe that this is a
very, very important year.
One of the reasons is the
picture on here, of course,
it's Paris.
And there was the
historic climate deal,
which I suspect some of
you-- I know some of you
were at in December.
And we think that's going
to be a game changer.
So let me plunge right in.
And then we'll have a
discussion afterwards.
And you may have
your own stories,
or you may disagree
with these stories.
But I hope it at least
stimulates some thought.
Look, this is a difficult
world we live in right now.
The past year has been
extraordinarily difficult.
More refugees in
the last year than
any year since World War II.
For us as Americans,
hard to really realize
how important it is.
But in Europe, it's
been a game changer.
So too, terrorism
spiked last year
in a very, very dangerous way.
It is a dangerous
world we live in.
And the economy is also
in pretty bad shape.
As we enter 2016,
the worst economic
start to any year
for several decades.
And all of the projections of
the world economy are gloomy.
So it's sort of a rather
dismal time-- or is it?
Remarkable signs of hope.
In the last year,
I was privileged
to be in this room-- it's the
General Assembly of the United
Nations-- last September
when the Pope spoke.
And after the
Pope, Shakira sang.
And you notice, she's actually
dressed quite similarly
to the Pope.
And you'll notice also,
here everyone is sitting.
But when Shakira started
singing, they were stood up,
you see.
And after Shakira
sang, the entire world
represented by 196 countries
approved unanimously
the sustainable
development goals.
And I'm going to talk
about that in a minute.
These are goals to 2030 and
a very, very important thing.
And then just
three months later,
we had this in Paris,
basically, a historic agreement
on climate.
And so what 2016 is
all about is moving,
if you like, from
commitments and agreements
to real action on the ground,
getting the plumbing right,
doing the investment.
And so the stories I'm
going to talk about
are mainly related to
that-- how are we now going
to get on with it and deliver.
And obviously, the
first story is about,
will the momentum that
countries committed to in Paris,
will it continue?
Now what actually
happened in Paris?
And some of you know
this, some won't.
I mean never before have we
had 187 countries saying,
we are going to be part of the
solution to climate change.
So too, never before have
we had a long-term goal
of decarbonization
of the world economy.
Every five years countries
are to come back and raise
their level of ambition.
Every country has to agree
to common transparency
about how they measure
their emissions.
We've got good
agreements on adaptation,
and we've got some
financial support.
So this is really important.
This is where we were heading
in terms of temperature.
Because of the
commitments in Paris,
this is where we're heading now.
It's still 4.8 to 6.6
degrees Fahrenheit.
This is where Paris
agreed we needed to be.
So whilst this is a huge
achievement what countries
have committed it is
not enough, and we
need to continually
ramp up the ambition.
So on the 22nd of April, all
the countries in the world
will meet again to officially
sign the declaration at Paris.
And we'll learn a lot then as
to whether or not the level
of passion and commitment that
existed in Paris will continue.
And it's important that it does
because business community is
not yet sure whether it's real.
This is what we did at the
World Economic Forum last month.
They ask 1,000 opinion makers--
CEOs of major corporations.
And the question
was, of 50 risks,
which is the one that
worries you the most?
And along here, it
is the likelihood
of the risk happening.
Up here is the impact
if it does happen.
The number one risk up here
for business people of all
is not whether interest
rates will fall or rise
or they'll be a recession.
It is there'll be a
failure in climate change.
This is the business community
saying, this matters to us.
So these are the countries
that are committed to actually
address carbon emissions.
The blue ones are committed to
actually reduce tons of carbon.
The green ones, they are
committed to reduce carbon
as a share of their
national income.
And so we will know
throughout this year
whether there is a seriousness
about implementing that.
And we also need to look at
some specific countries who
have made specific
sectoral commitments.
So India, for example, is
a hugely important country
as you know.
They have committed under the
new prime minister, Narendra
Modi, to investing 100
gigawatts of solar.
Today it's three
The predecessor
government said, by 2022,
we're going to do 20 gigawatts.
And prime minister
Modi said, no.
By 2022, we're going
to do 100 gigawatts.
So we will know this
year whether there's
a seriousness about that.
So that's story number 1.
It is, will there be
momentum from countries?
Story number 2 is
similar to that,
but it doesn't
apply to countries.
It applies to corporations,
and it applies to city mayors.
Because in Paris, it wasn't only
the countries that committed.
It was really amazing
commitments from corporations
and from cities.
This was just one meeting
that I had the privilege
to be at and speak at, which had
about 70 CEOs from companies.
Paris, more than 1,000
companies committed
to put a price on
carbon, for example.
150 US companies committed
to support aggressive climate
action.
120 companies is
committed to what are
called science-based targets.
In other words, we
won't only do better.
We will do enough
based on the science.
And what we'll be looking for
this year is whether there
are more companies that
actually are going to say,
here's what our target is
to be part of the solution.
These are ones that
have already announced
precisely what
they will be doing
in terms of greenhouse gases.
And they're going to
monitor that year by year
and be accountable to that.
So too, Google has
been as you know
perhaps the leader in the
world on renewable energy.
And we have some
of our friends here
that are leading that work,
both on your purchasing side,
but also on your investing side.
And Google has really
led the pack in many ways
on what's called
RE100-- a commitment
to be 100% reliant
on renewable energy.
And of course,
Google not only is
100% going to rely on that
for the energy you need.
You are also generating
gigawatts-- you will be.
You're already generating 2
gigawatts for your own leads,
but you're going to be
generating gigawatts.
They're astonishing commitments.
One of the things we're
looking at in this coming
year for the private sector
is, all of these companies that
made these commitments and
gave fabulous speeches,
will their trade associations
and will their lobbying efforts
be consistent with that?
We recently did a study, and we
saw that 60% of major companies
say the right
things, but of that,
only one quarter of that number
actually align their lobbying
towards that end.
And one of the great
things about Google
is you're very consistent.
And we would love to see an
even greater profile of you
lobbying to actually
get the government
into the right place.
And so this is a
very important story
to watch because trade
associations generally
lag their members
in wanting change.
So Chamber of
Commerce and others
are still, quite frankly, rather
old fashioned in their views
on some of these important
issues on sustainability.
That was the private sector.
But equally important-- mayors.
Something like 500
mayors went to Paris.
This is Mayor Bloomberg,
who sort of led the charges,
the Paris city hall.
And 425 committed to what's
called the compact of mayors.
And what they said is we
will be transparent about
and we will measure
and be transparent
about our greenhouse gases.
And we will have
goals that are more
ambitious than our nations.
And what we're going
to do this coming year
is really to monitor this.
We're helping many of
these cities measure,
and we're going to see, is there
seriousness in this enthusiasm?
Is it continued?
And one of the important things
that will happen this year
will happen in October.
Every 20 years, they have a
big conference called Habitat.
And this one is the
first for 20 years.
And the question will
be, is the new way
of doing city is going
to be the theme of this?
Because it turns out
that whether or not
we win or lose the battle
against climate change,
we depend upon how
we design our cities.
And the moment cities
can be the problem,
or cities can be the solution.
Two cities with the
same population, one
can have 10 times the
carbon emissions of another.
And what we're learning now is
if you actually design cities
around people rather
than around automobiles,
you can have a more efficient
as well as a more sustainable
city.
So that's the second
story for 2016.
The third story is this, which
relates directly to all of you.
I told you that there were the
sustainable development goals.
This was New York City
when they were announced.
These are very, very important.
I mean this is the entire
world agreeing on the goals it
will have for 2030.
And this is how
they're organized.
So there's goals on poverty,
on ending hunger, health,
education, et cetera.
And down here, the decent work,
clean energy, climate, oceans,
forests, inequality--
so you see all of these.
And there are 17 goals.
And there are 169 targets.
So a target, for
example, could be
to double the rate of
renewable energy, say.
And there, it's going to
be 200 proposed indicate.
The story for 2016
is, are they going
to really use modern
techniques to measure progress?
And that gets into the kind of
thing that we do with Google.
So for example, how will
they choose to measure?
The old fashioned
way of measuring
is to get some UN agency to
spend a long time collecting
data, publish a thick report.
And gradually it
reaches governments,
and slowly it might
affect decisions.
But nowadays, we have 1,261
satellites up there every day
beaming back
unbelievable information.
And there are people in this
room that know more about how
to turn these billions
of data points
into information in a
user-friendly way sitting
on the desk of a minister
of finance in Jakarta
than anyone else on the planet.
And it will be transformative
if we get this right.
So for example,
agricultural productivity.
We can do 1,000 different
soil samples and all that.
Or we can also use
remote sensing, which
can actually predict harvests.
Consider GDP even.
This is work that you guys do.
You can actually predict sales
by lots of simple little tricks
and algorithms.
This is counting cars in a
car park in a shopping mall.
Doing that right,
learning, continually
revising the algorithms
in the relationship,
you can get real data in the
hands of real decision makers
much, much quicker in a
very transformative way.
We can even measure
poverty differently.
I think you guys are
also involved in this.
Poverty measurement is
exceedingly difficult
if it has to be done
by household surveys.
We still should do
that, but then there
are tricks of actually
using proxies, for example,
using remote sensing.
I'd love to go into
that-- what kind of roof,
how many have changed the roof,
all kinds of things like that.
This is what we were talking.
Rebecca mentioned
Global Forest Watch.
Again, transformative.
In the old days, I remember
talking to President Yudhoyono
of Indonesia.
He said, I don't know if my
forest policies in Kalimantan
are being honored
because I get something
like a year and a half late.
And so I don't know.
He says, now I've got
something that tells
me what happened last week.
And it tells me exactly
where it happened.
So I know exactly
who to blame and who
to send where to solve it.
This is a very, very
remarkable thing.
We'd love to talk
to you about it
much more because without
you this would not exist.
It's a really wonderful thing.
And we are seeing
all around the world,
every single
country in the world
has now used this for
serious policy decisions,
except for North
Korea to [INAUDIBLE].
So if anybody has
links in North Korea,
we would love to
make it complete.
So that's land use change.
And so too, we're using
the same technique now
for actually assessing carbon
emissions from deforestation.
We launched Paris,
again, with you,
where due to a lot of
advances in the way
we understand emissions of
carbon from deforestation,
we're able to do that.
And there are just so
many applications of this
that I would love to talk about.
So too on water.
Collecting data on water
is exceedingly difficult.
We now have some fairly
sophisticated modeling
capabilities across 15,000
of the main watersheds
in the world.
And now for the
first time ever we
are using remote
sensing to actually look
at a water quality, which we've
never managed to do before.
So this is a very, very
important issue for 2016
as the world begins to implement
its sustainable development
goals.
And together with
Google-- I think
we're partners together in
this idea of resource watch--
is basically saying, OK, what we
did for Global Forest Watch is
fine.
We're not going to put
lots of different overlays.
So they will be very,
very easy to actually do
all kinds of comparisons
and look at relationships.
This is going to be a
very big project for us,
which we are planning
to launch this year.
And we are really thrilled to
be doing it together with you.
Let me just give you one
example of the kind of thing
that will be on this.
We can project a water risk
using 12 different indicators
using projections
from the IPCC, which
is the scientific body
that tells us what
will happen on climate change.
And then we overlay,
for example,
all these black things.
The color is how
intense the water
risk is and whether or not
it's going to be changing,
getting worse.
The black marks are
actually coal, coal plants
to generate electricity.
Why are these two
relevant together?
You need an awful
lot of water in order
to generate electricity
from coal, for example.
So if you are an Indian, a
minister responsible for energy
security, this is extremely
helpful and actually
very worrying information.
That's an example of how
putting different layers on top
of each other actually
make a huge difference.
If you do the same by the way
of this on irrigated water,
you see a really astonishing
worrying situation
for food security
because you see
that the average irrigated
hectare in South Asia
may today need to
feed 28 people.
It will need to feed
42 people at a time
when water risk
and water scarcity
will increase very
substantially.
So you start getting the idea
of just how this could be.
So what will this mean for the
implementation of these goals?
We believe it will
be transformative.
And actually, Google is very
central in a way that I'm sure
some of you have thought
about, but many of you
haven't-- central actually to
the sustainable development
goals and the extent to which
decision makers all around
the world, whether they're
prime ministers and presidents
or whether they are CEOs of
companies or whether they are
village leaders
can really affect.
So that was story number
three-- the transformative role
of big data.
And I didn't talk about
artificial intelligence--
I'd love to-- because that
is the coming thing which
will radically change the
ability of policymakers
to make decisions
quickly and effectively
and get real-time
feedback from them.
Story number 4--
quite different.
And you may wonder why
it's such a big story.
I mean food waste.
I mean is it that important?
And the answer is
yes, it really is.
One third of all
food in the world
is wasted as you produce it,
and it never actually enters
anybody's mouth.
It's incredibly expensive.
A trillion, almost,
a year is wasted
as a result of
that at a time when
we're going to need to
increase food intake by 70%
by 2050, which will require
agricultural productivity
growth to be greater than it's
been for the last 40 years
at a time when we don't have a
whole lot more forests to cut
down and expand agriculture.
So you get the point.
So too, think about this.
Food loss and waste is
equivalent to planting
every single acre in
the United States,
including where there are
buildings and roads, with food,
tending it, fertilizing it,
watering it for a whole year.
And then letting half of it rot,
and then burn the other half.
That's what food
loss and wastes are.
The entire United States--
continental United States.
I mean you imagine what this
is doing to natural habitats
because we're having to take a
lot more land for agriculture
than we need.
And finally, it's a dreadful
emitter of greenhouse gases.
If food loss and
waste were a country,
it would be the third
biggest emitter in the world
just after the United States.
So you start getting the idea
of why this is important.
This is very, very
important indeed.
And that's why one of the
sustainable development targets
is to halve food loss
and waste by 2030.
This was the United
Nations same meeting.
This is where it was
agreed to do that.
And the big question
is, will that happen?
The first thing we need
is a global standard
on how you measure food
loss and waste, which we
are privileged to be designing.
The consumer goods forum
has now adopted that.
These are 400 members.
They have agreed, not only to
adopt that common standard,
but to cut their own food loss
and waste by half by 2025.
The United States, within one
week of the global target being
set, announced that they would--
we would, here, cut food loss
and waste by half.
It's going to be
very, very difficult.
This is Tom Vilsack speaking.
He's the Secretary
of Agriculture.
Gina McCarthy on the
right-- she's head of EPA--
are basically making
that announcement.
And so too what we've done
is realize that, actually, it
will be impossible, at a time
when food loss and waste is
currently rising, to reduce
it by half, unless there
is a political and a
psychological switch that
goes on.
So we've created something
called Champions 12.3
because this target is
called Target 12.3 in the UN.
This is a guy who
is head of Nestle,
who is one of the champions.
We put together
30 champions that
will take it upon them--
they're all CEOs of corporations
or ministers from
developing countries
and from rich countries.
It's headed by the CEO of Tesco,
which is the second biggest
retailer in the
world and the one
that is really out front
together with Walmart
on trying to address this.
Food loss and waste is
almost exactly the same
in the developing
world as a share as it
is in the rich world, but
for very different reasons.
In the developing
world, it's food loss.
In other words, it's
difficult to store the food,
or rats eat it, and so
on, or it gets mildewy.
In the rich
countries, it's waste.
In other words, we don't consume
everything that is there.
And so we're working on this.
This is going to be a big
emerging story in 2016.
OK.
Heading into the
home straight now.
So that was story number 4.
There's just two
more left, so I hope
we'll have plenty
time for discussion.
Story number 5-- China
really has to be a story.
China is going through
an extraordinary sort
of transition.
For the last 25 years,
this has been China.
China has increased its real
income 10 times in 25 years.
Can you imagine that?
I mean no country in the
history of the world, especially
a big one, has come
close to doing that.
I mean it's been spectacular.
So no wonder they're
looking so happy.
But actually, it's not going
so well right now as you know.
There are issues of economic
management, a huge sort
of volatility in the stock
market, the perceptions
of whether or not they'll slow
down or be a hard landing.
And this is happening.
This is now reaching an extend
that is extremely severe.
Last November,
for the first time
ever, they declared what
they call a Red Alert.
They closed down schools
in many northern cities.
They closed down factories
because it was simply
too dangerous.
Now, nobody needs to tell
the Chinese authorities
that this is a problem.
They know it full well.
And that's why President
Xi on downwards
continually says, look, we've
got to do things differently.
We simply can't rely on the
quantity of growth anymore.
We need to think this through.
And China is the first
country in the world
that, recognizing it's got very
serious environmental problems,
is saying we actually can't
just stop that at the margin.
We've got to change the
way we run our economy.
And so in March this
year, next month,
China will approve its
next five-year plan.
And the question is,
just how bold will it be?
We know quite a bit
already about it.
But one of the things, for
example, we'll be looking at,
is will China continue
to be the world
leader in renewable energy?
China already last year
invested $101 billion,
which in the United States,
we invested $40 billion here.
And Europe invested $45 billion.
So China is twice
the level already.
And we think they're
going to become even more
ambitious because they believe
in this very, very strongly.
So too, watch for what
they're doing on coal.
This may not seem
interesting to you.
But in terms of the
world and sustainability,
China's coal is
unbelievably important.
And the question is,
when will it peak?
And the last two
years, it's actually
been falling a little bit.
So that's very encouraging.
So they're actually
using less coal today
than they used two
and a half years ago.
And it may well be that it's
now on a downward pattern.
They've already declared
a number of cities
to be banned for coal.
And the question is, whether
they'll put more caps on it
or whether they'll instruct
their banking system to stop
lending so much money for coal.
So too, as you may know,
just as we in this country
decided not to have a cap and
trade system-- do you remember?
The Congress was
not ready for it.
China is implementing one as
announced that by next year,
we'll have a nationwide cap
and trade system on carbon.
And it's doing some pilots now
in seven cities and provinces.
This year, we will
learn a lot about that.
And finally in China, in many
ways, the most important thing
of all will be, how
will they change the way
they manage their cities?
Chinese cities have been
growing very rapidly
just like they are in India
and they will in Africa.
And the way they expand
is by selling land
further and further
out into the suburbs.
And as a result of that,
people can take two or three
hours to get to work.
And they lose 10% of their city
income just due to incongestion
and another 10%
due to pollution.
And so that's the terrible
drag on the economy.
It's a drag on society as well.
And now China is
saying, wait a minute.
That doesn't make any sense.
Let's see if we can
do it differently.
Let's design cities
around people, rather than
around automobiles.
And let's see if we can learn
for some modern city thinking.
And so the building stock in
China will triple by 2030.
So there's lots
of opportunities.
In the case of India,
it will quadruple.
So there's still
time to get it right,
but there's a real danger
of serious lock in.
So that's the story for China.
Will it rebalance its economy?
And in 2016, we will
learn a lot about China,
and the stakes are very high.
The final story has to be
about the United States.
Will the United
States continue to be
a leader on climate change.
And some very good things have
happened recently as you know.
Very surprisingly, the Congress
approved continued investment
tax credits for solar.
And by the way,
some of the policies
that they're putting in
place at the state level,
Google is being a great advocate
of, green tariffs, and so on.
This is actually a very,
very important development.
So too, the United
States, the federal level
has put a stay, a pause, on
coal from state-owned land,
the Bureau of Land Management.
This is a very important thing.
40% of all the coal
in this country
is dug up on federal land.
And a lot of people
would say, wait a minute.
Does that make sense
when we're trying to move
towards a healthier future?
And of course, the
Clean Power Plant plan
was finalized last year, which
is a very, very dramatic policy
introduced by President Obama.
And that enabled
the United States
to announce some very ambitious
goals with regard to greenhouse
gas emissions-- 26% to 28%.
But two weeks ago, the Supreme
Court said, wait a minute.
Since there are so many
suits against the EPA
coming from states, nobody
needs to do anything
until we decide on this.
So this decision was
the very last one
that Justice Scalia made.
And on this particular issue,
he was on the wrong side
by the way.
He was not a friend necessarily
to President Obama's
environmental policy.
So this is rather up in the
air right now, quite frankly.
27 states are suing
the federal government
at the moment over this issue.
And why does the Clean
Power Plant rule matter?
It matters because
for the first time
ever power plants
are going to have
to measure their greenhouse
gas emissions and limit it.
And that means really
sort of a very grim future
for coal-- so 27 states.
Now, before the Supreme
Court made its decision,
38 of those states were
actually still preparing
for this rule, which would have
pretty important implications.
Now a number of those are
saying, wait a minute.
We don't need to.
So they're backing off.
And some states though,
including your own,
are saying, not at all.
We are going to
press on with this.
And New York state and
several others are saying,
we believe this is
good for our citizens.
So there's a lot to play
for on this by the way.
And it's a very,
very important issue.
Related to this-- and
I say this because I
know there are some of you
from the energy business here,
and others might not
be so interested.
How US utilities
respond is actually
a very, very interesting
issue this year.
We're working on this issue
with a number of utilities
and a number of purchasers.
And obviously, Google is one
of the most important ones
of all, signed up to a project
that we call the Clean Buyers
Club.
And so the question
is, will utilities
come into the 21st century?
Electricity utilities
have traditionally
been very, very
conservative institutions.
And they are going
to have to change.
And the question
is, are we going
to see progress
even although we've
had this delay in the
Clean Power Plant rule.
In June, the Court of Appeals
is set to hear the cases,
but it won't be decided at
the Supreme Court for at least
a year after that.
So this is a delay
that's important.
It's not the end of the
world, but it is nonetheless
quite important.
And related to this is how
the world responds to this.
If you read, for example,
"The New York Times,"
Delay of the Clean
Power Plant Stokes Worry
About the Paris Climate Treaty.
There's a, Blow to Emissions
Efforts May Imperil
the Paris Climate Accord.
We are talking to a lot of
developing countries now
saying, relax.
It's not so bad.
Don't worry.
You were right to trust
the United States.
This is just sort of a
delay, but nonetheless this
is something we have to monitor
because the entire Paris
climate deal depends precisely
upon trust and mutuality.
And so it's very
important that we're
able to show that the others
should continue to be ambitious
because the United States will
in time be able to be ambitious
as well.
What to watch for also this
year is, will President Obama
in the remaining
months, will he continue
to do things that he
believes are right
even though many in
the opposition party
don't think so?
And so there are a number
of executive actions--
we spend a lot of
time analyzing these--
that could be made that
could actually improve
the situation quite a bit.
And we list some of them there.
And finally this year,
watch out for what
these guys talk
about with regard
to sustainability
and climate change.
These two talk about it a lot.
These ones don't talk
about it so much.
In fact, it's not
entirely their fault.
Five days after the Paris
climate deal was signed,
there was a Republican
debate hosted
by CNN and not a single
question about climate change.
And that's really not
good enough, we think.
We think these guys ought
to be addressing it.
And so too, the final slide is,
what will happen in November?
Will we see a nation that really
understands that the future is
about a greener, cleaner,
more efficient, more socially
friendly future?
Or will it not?
And over the last
three or four years,
there's been an amazing
intellectual breakthrough
with regard to a recognition
that you can grow your economy
and address
environmental problems.
And indeed, addressing
environmental problems
will actually help
you grow your economy.
Google sits at the
heart of this debate
and, better than almost
any country and any company
on the planet, has the
ability to articulate
what this is all about.
And that's why we really
love having the partnership
with you.
Thank you, Rebecca.
And thank you, all of you.
Now you can rebut.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: I mean it's obviously
embedded in all of these.
I think it's difficult
to tell anyone
in the world you
can't have babies.
That's kind of a human right.
In a way, I think it is, but
it's also a huge problem.
I just wonder what WRI's and
your opinion is about that.
ANDREW STEER: Well, look, Abby.
You're right.
It is totally a human right.
The sort of median
expectations now
are that population will
rise to 9.6 billion by 2050.
And when I said food intake
will have to increase by 70%,
it's partly that.
It's partly also that
another three billion
will enter the middle class.
And when you enter
the middle class,
you change your eating habits.
You eat a lot more
meat and so on.
And so yes, it is.
But our view would be that
educate women, girls, girls
and women, and that is the
most effective way together
with ensuring adequate
services are provided.
I think the world has lost
the weight a little bit
on population over
the last 15 years.
And one of the
reasons for that is
that many of the countries
that were very much part
of the debate now have problems
of too little population
growth.
And so there's a number
of rich countries now
that are deeply troubled
by declining populations.
And if there's one
thing more difficult,
if your an economic manager
of a country, one thing
more difficult than a very
rapidly rising population,
it's declining populations.
It just does not
work because you
get dependency ratios of too
many old people and so on.
And so it's a real problem.
So I totally agree.
This is a big issue.
Because there are other
groups that work on this,
we don't have
specifically a program.
But in our major flagship
document this year,
which was on the
future of food, we
had a whole chapter on why
population growth matters.
AUDIENCE: I think this probably
fits into building cities
around people, not cars.
But I'm curious if you
can share some stories
around transportation
and maybe some light
at the end of the tunnel
of what that's looking.
Any projects that
are happening that
will help transform some
of that [INAUDIBLE].
ANDREW STEER: Yes.
We have quite a large
transportation program
in about 40 cities in
the emerging world.
There have been some revolutions
that don't sound very exciting,
but actually are, for example,
bus rapid transit, which
is when you take
up part of the road
and you protect it for buses.
In places like Mexico City,
even Shanghai now, Bangalore,
places like that,
you're actually
seeing amazing impacts.
Now 200 cities have that.
And what we show is that
it costs about 1/10 what
an underground metro
would cost but has
90% of the benefits in
terms of time saved.
And what we've seen
in Mexico City,
for example, where poor people
are living on the periphery.
Took 3 hours to get to work
in the morning, three hours
to get home.
So they had to leave at like
5 o'clock in the morning,
didn't get home till
9 o'clock at night.
Never saw their children,
couldn't help them
with their homework.
I mean really sort of
tragic that we've now
seen that cut by almost
an hour just introducing
some modern techniques.
But at the end of the day,
these are political choices
as to whether or not leaders
have the courage to say,
I'm going to put money into
public transportation that
benefits all the citizens.
Or am I going to put it in roads
that, in developing countries,
benefit the top 10%.
So you've got this real
tragedy in many countries
where you see people sitting
in air-conditioned cars
going down the street.
Although now, they're
being stuck in traffic,
while the poor people are having
to change buses four times.
And the buses get stuck
just the same way,
so they take even longer.
Very interesting
question will be--
and it's hotly debated
among environmentalists--
is self-driving cars,
which obviously Google
is the leader in.
The question is from
sustainability standpoint,
good or bad?
It's good, clearly, in that cars
will move more smoothly, more
efficiently, and
obviously in a much less
polluting sort of way,
less stopping and starting.
And of course, that will
be electric in time.
But some are saying,
well, is it going
to get in the way of
public transportation.
I don't think it needs
to at all actually.
I mean I think
there should still
be a way of combining the two.
But there does need to be
the kind of bold action
that cities like London
took, where, for example-- I
grew up in London.
I used to drive into
London all the time,
all ride into central London.
That's how we used to get there.
And about 15 years ago,
the government said,
we're going to charge to go
into the middle of London.
We're going to charge
electronically.
So as you pass through
this, you get eight pounds
taken off your credit card.
Interestingly, that's
not very much money.
It's not the money
that changes this.
But because of that
psychological shift--
I just lived three years
in the suburb of London.
Never once in that three
years did I drive into London.
And I would die before I
ever drive into London again.
I will never ever drive a
car in the center of London.
How could that switch happen?
And that's what needs to happen.
And Beijing now has
asked us to help
them think through a
similar system for Beijing.
And there's a lot of
complicated issues of technology
and, more important, political
acceptability of course.
So we're simply doing the
technical work with them,
taking them to a place like
Stockholm and Singapore
and London and showing
them how to do that.
I understand that Mayor
Bloomberg in New York, who
obviously was a
wonderful mayor-- this
was the one, I
think, sort of regret
that he tried to move forward
on congestion pricing,
as it's called.
And couldn't get the
political support for it
because it is difficult.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
On the food loss and waste,
besides the agricultural remote
sensing, what
other opportunities
do you see for
applications of technology?
And what are some things
that us sitting in this room
can be doing?
ANDREW STEER: Wow.
Good question.
Actually, I haven't thought
about that, and I'd have to.
I think for rich
countries-- Tesco
just came out with its
annual statement and said,
we want to come clean.
55,000 tons of food in
our care was wasted.
That's not when you take
it home, you don't eat it
or your kids throw it away.
It's within the care of Tesco.
And they said, we want
to be transparent,
and every year we're going to.
So the question is,
what do they do?
I mean they need-- which
they're doing and so is Walmart.
They need very sophisticated
logistical, just-in-time
inventories and so on.
I mean there's just lots
of tricks that they do.
So to the extent that that
requires the kind of high tech
sophisticated support
that a company like Google
could provide, that's one.
With regard to
developing countries,
I think that-- I mean the
issue there is for 20-30 years,
we've all known that it's
a terrible, terrible waste
to see these poor farmers
slaving and getting
yields which are not very high.
And then half of
the food sometimes
is lost simply because
they don't have storage.
There are new technologies now
that enable that to be kept.
And of course, the existence
of distributed power
enables for certain crops'
power to be used just
to keep the temperature a
little bit cooler, which
can dramatically affect the
sustainability of the food
for another month or so.
Do you know what I mean?
And then obviously, the
more sophisticated crops
is all about cold storage.
And there, again,
that comes into it.
But the prediction--
I mean remote sensing
is potentially
exceedingly important.
If you can see what a crop is
going to be by remote sensing
before the crop is harvested--
if two months before the crop
is harvested you know it's
going to be a bumper crop,
that has all kinds
of implications
of how you're going
to store your food
and how you're going
to get it to market.
And it enables you
to get a start-- do
you know what I mean-- to
get us a start on things.
So there are some exciting
possibilities I think.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thanks for speaking today.
I think that major
players in sustainability
are continually seeing
issues like social justice
and public health
as really being
central to environmental
sustainability, whereas that's
been a little bit more
segmented in the past.
And I wanted to know where you
think our key points of overlap
that are going to
be really important,
not just for environmental
sustainability,
but issues of public
health, where we can sort of
kill two birds with one stone.
ANDREW STEER: Well,
I think, I mean
if there's one truth
about environmental damage
is that, in almost
all situations--
air pollution may be
an exception-- it hurts
the poor more than the rich.
In most environmental
problems, the rich
are able, one way or the other,
to buy their way out of it.
So most cities, if
you look at them,
historically, the poor people
live downwind and down river
often.
So in London-- say, my city,
but it's true of all cities--
east end of London,
always the poor area.
West end of London?
Rich people.
Why?
Because the west end of
London, air is cleaner,
water is cleaner, and so on.
Do you know what I mean?
I'll pollute you down.
There's a general truth
that if you address
environmental issues smartly,
you will benefit the poor
and you will advance the
cause of social justice.
And climate change is
clearly the case in point--
the most dramatic case.
I mean there are
many studies now
that show the impacts of
climate change on the poor
will be really desperate.
That's why one of
the things that we do
is we run a network of
300 organizations in 50
countries dedicated to
giving citizens the right
to have environmental data.
It's called the
Access Initiative.
And we publish something.
We've just started
to publish it.
We're going to do
it every year, what
we call an environmental
democracy index.
And what that does
is it says, look,
we think that everybody has
the right to know, at least,
and to engage in decisions.
So for example,
does a country have
user-friendly data on air
pollution in the capital city?
China now is a leader in that.
They certainly
weren't 10 years ago.
But our staff in China
wake up every morning.
They check on their smartphone
what the air pollution is.
And that, they decide
whether to putting a mask on
to go do their
work, so to speak.
So environmental democracy
means that all citizens
have the right to
get information
and the right to engage
in decision making.
So I think the links
are incredibly close.
REBECCA MOORE: I know
you have a question,
but if you don't mind,
I'd like to ask one.
There's a story that is in
the news about the extinction
crisis.
Is this working?
Now it is.
That there's an accelerating
loss of plant and animal
species, hundreds if not
thousands of species going
extinct accelerating rate.
And it seems to be due to
climate change and habitat
loss.
I think something like
90% of endangered species
are dependent on forests.
And so as forests
are cut down, we
are eliminating these species.
E.O. Wilson is apparently coming
out with something [INAUDIBLE]
50% of nature.
He's like a leading biologist,
ecologist at Harvard.
That the idea is we
can't save all of nature,
but can we agree to
save 50% of nature
and agree on where that
is and draw the line?
And Eric Dinerstein of WRI I
believe is involved with this.
This book is going to
come out this year.
Anyway, so what is your, what
is WRI's position on all that?
ANDREW STEER: That's
a brilliant question.
One of the real puzzles is,
why is biodiversity and species
loss not a big political issue?
I mean it's really interesting.
I was at the original
Rio Earth Summit in 1992.
And there we saw two
treaties being signed--
climate change, biodiversity.
In the next five
years, biodiversity
was a much hotter issue
than climate change.
I mean it was really a
buzzy important issue.
And in the last 15 years,
it's totally fallen
off the agenda, which
is really interesting,
whilst climate change
actually has done rather well.
And even the stories I tell,
you notice, they're about that.
So I don't know whether E.O.
Wilson's 50% is the right
or not, but we absolutely
need to demonstrate
how the kinds of things
we're talking about
will affect biodiversity.
I mean our view is, quite
frankly, that we are hoping--
and we're working
with IUCN in the lead
up to the big IUCN
conference in Hawaii
later on this year, which
they have every three years.
We're hoping to get
some more political buzz
around biodiversity.
But in the meantime,
quite frankly,
the policies of smart
cities-- cutting food waste,
addressing knowledge on forests,
addressing supply chains
on palm oil and soy--
do you know what I mean?
Those other ways,
practical ways,
even though you don't say
that's why we're doing them.
But it would be great.
Eric Dinerstein is just
this wonderful fellow.
And we're using Global Forest
Watch now for tiger protection.
It's fabulous.
That's such a great question.
REBECCA MOORE: I think I have
time for one more question.
You've been patiently waiting.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
Yeah.
Thanks.
So I like eating meat, you know?
I enjoy it.
But I think I'm lucky
enough to be in a position
where if I didn't have to eat
meat or meat were restricted,
I would be fine not eating
meat-- being vegetarian.
You mentioned food waste and
the sort of ecological impact,
but I'm wondering whether the
reduction of meat consumption
is something that comes
up in these conversations.
I mean we know it contributes
to global warming in a huge way,
especially in
affluent nations where
people don't have to eat meat.
Is that something that's
being talked about?
Is that a part of the
conversation at all?
ANDREW STEER: Yeah.
So it's a really important
part of the conversation,
and it's a really good question.
Why do humans change
their behavior?
Why do they sometimes not
change for a long time and then
suddenly they will switch?
And there is a very important
field of psychology,
and commercial psychology,
that has learned a lot.
And so what we're
doing is setting up
a small lab precisely
to look at the issue of,
what it would take to get
people to eat less meat?
And part of that
is, for example,
even if you can get the
leading providers of food
in supermarkets to position
things differently,
and little things like that, and
the whole science of nudge now.
That's really what it's about.
How do you not sort
of preach at them--
I mean interestingly,
the reason there's
been this massive shift
in smoking, turns out,
actually, is not only or not
mainly because the government
has passed rules actually.
It's much more to do
with social pressure,
and it's to do with nudging.
It's labeling.
It's all things like that.
So we believe this is
very, very important.
REBECCA MOORE: Well, I
think we could probably
go on for another hour.
You are such a font
of information.
Please join me in
thanking Dr. Steer.
ANDREW STEER: Thank
you very much.
[APPLAUSE]